it is a sobering place to be during the
pandemic
the seoul crematorium in the eastern
german town of mycen
where hundreds of coffins bodies inside
are piled high
the cause of death of so many chalked
onto the sides
in the basement the workers and the
furnaces operate around the clock
they have to last month they cremated
1400 bodies here
double the number the year before more
than half of the dead
had the virus even the chapel is now a
storage facility
the chairs which before covid would have
accommodated mourners
taken away on some days recently coffins
were lined up in the car park outside
it's a stark reminder
as we leave another coffin arrives no
loved ones to accompany it because of
covered restrictions
this part of germany has experienced
almost double the national average
number of cases of covid
and residents are contemplating why mice
in the saxony region has one of the
highest covered rates in the country and
yet
if you look around people seem to be
obeying the rules
most staying at home those who are out
wearing masks
and yet there are factors about mycen
which could make its residents more
vulnerable
the age of the population and mycen's
location
next to other covid hotspot countries
the problem is in the eastern part of
germany we have also
very old people and here are living the
old people and the old people have
more problems with corona than the young
people you know that that is the reason
that we have more
diet people than in other regions
it's pity
it's upsetting yes
it's upsetting us covered numbers in
germany are now falling but the
government
worried about new variants has extended
a lockdown in the country
it's not like by everyone the far-right
afd
is big in saxony and believes angela
merkel has got it wrong
since
but even more stringent measures are on
the cards at this police facility in the
region
rooms are being converted to detain
people who repeatedly break coveted
rules
the german government determined not to
see the numbers head in the wrong
direction
again michelle clifford sky news mycen
germany